jetzt ist es leider amtlich deutschland
leidet unter chronischer landflucht sagt
das berlin-institut für bevölkerung und
entwicklung in einer neuen studie
die menschen ziehen immer mehr in die
städte auf dem land verhöhnen ganze
region ja ein riesenproblem ein
riesenproblem
vor allem im osten aber nicht nur da und
während sich in der großstadt singles
und familien buchstäblich um die letzte
freie wohnung grübeln verfallen auf dem
land die gebäude bewohnern liegt sein
dass die menschen trinken zb ein weg
ziehen
eigentlich schien ihn nicht weg venedig
ziemlich weckt die die sterben mehr
wirken
was jetzt nicht so viel besser ist große
städte wachsen zu lasten der ländlichen
regionen die langsam ausbluten in
sachsen anhalt zum beispiel wird die
bevölkerung in den nächsten 15 jahren um
16 prozent schrumpfen
und leider gehen ja immer die jungen und
die gut ausgebildeten das nennt man
brain drain also das gehirn läuft quasi
außer hier ein beitrag über die kleine
gemeinde wald toren hinten raus ja
unglücklich bebildert darauf dass auch
hier in zukunft immer mehr senioren
leben wollen sie vorbereitet sein
ein gesundheitszentrum haben sie schon
doch alte menschen wollen auch gepflegt
werden
oma wir sind fertig kannst dich rein
legen ja ich fürchte ja sechs
bildschirme
das ist ja das ist ja keine
schwarzmalerei ich fürchte manche dörfer
holt sich die natur nach und nach zurück
bleiben dann am ende nur die wölfe es
ist ja so es ist ja so ein anderes
großes problem ist der ärztemangel
allein in nrw gehen in den nächsten zehn
jahren mehr als die hälfte der
niedergelassenen hausärzte in den
ruhestand
hier neue folge vom lande
[Musik]
best bevor wir immer ja ja ich weiß
es wird schön in manchen dörfern würden
sich die frustrierten rest bewohner am
liebsten vor den zug werfen
aber wie denn wenn da keiner mehr fährt
mit glück hält 12 mal am tag ein bus
weil eine panne hat aber aber keine
angst genau für solche probleme hat ingo
horst seehofer das nagelneue heimat
ministerium gegeben
seine heimat abteilung hat innerhalb
eines jahres nicht ein gesetz
eingereicht der minister selbst findet
es gar nicht schlimm ich konnte ihn
entsorgen da wirst du auch in zehn
jahren kein gesetz geben da bin ich ja
beruhigt
gut muss man erklären was onkel horst
meint seinen heimatverein macht keine
gesetze der entwickelt konzepte für
andere ministerien sagte sollen die dann
umsetzen und die groko verspricht dem
landvolk weiter gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse das steht so im
koalitionsvertrag gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse jedenfalls irgendwann
unnatürlich glasfaserkabel das ist ganz
wichtig meine damen und herren
glasfaserkabel löst sämtliche probleme
gerade auf dem land ja mit
glasfaserkabel können sogar die schweine
im stall den ganzen tag netflix gucken
beziehungsweise in diesem fall netflix
oder
wenn der bauer mal wieder mit der hand
in die häckselmaschine gekommen ist vor
dem dorf gibt keinen arzt einfach ab bin
den stumpf mit glasfaserkabel und vor
allem mit glasfaserkabel kann man junge
frauen daran hindern aus dem dorf in die
stadt zu flüchten
meine damen und herren ja ja klar ohne
internet das ist schrecklich dass ist
menschen unwohl wird durch netter sitzt
auf der weide und cooks den ganzen tag
coupon oder wie das heißt
was also tun viele aus dem land hier
heute oder ja was also tun investieren
oder aufgeben eine neue studie des
leibniz instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung sagt gerade er
aufgeben vor allem die fast verlassenen
dörfer im osten eine muss man sagen
echte premiere lektüre mit radikalen
vorschlägen und ein klarer fall für
gernot hassknecht
[Musik]
der buchte mit gernot hassknecht die
neuen länder schäumen vor wut über diese
studie vereintes land drei jahrzehnte
nach dem mauerfall ein etwas sperriger
titel griffiger wäre gewesen
ostdeutschland völlig im arsch kannste
wegschmeißen
klingt hart fast aber die studie sehr
gut zusammen 20 prozent weniger
produktivität als im westen alle neuen
länder liegen sogar weit hinter dem
saarland dabei ist das gar kein
richtiges bundesland sondern nur der
entzündeten blinddarm von rheinland
pfalz deswegen empfehlen die autoren nur
noch in ostdeutsche städte zu
investieren und ländliche region
komplett aufzugeben kam gar nicht gut an
wobei wir älteren menschen kennen das
gerade aus dem bereich der erotik auch
am körper gibt es regionen die müssen
wir irgendwann aufgeben
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich wasche ich
nicht mal mehr wozu aber verdammt noch
mal in diesen davon leben immer noch
menschen und da ist das das einzige
telefon und es geht
womit man maximal 0 traf betätigen
können ansonsten leere hülse einfach
aufgeben wenn in einem dorf unter 100
leute wohnen weg damit oder wenn 80 von
denen echt hässlich sind dann aber bitte
auch im westen dieser autobahnbrücke
dein leverkusen
die wird doch eh nie fertig abreifen
feierabend und wendy bagger sowieso da
sind mir braucht eigentlich das
ruhrgebiet deswegen zum schluss als
lesetipp mein neues buch recklinghausen
bohrkerne da wohnt wirklichkeit
guten abend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
michael b schreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren